- The biggest fear I have right now is
in my popularity growth
that people are gonna try to be like me.
I'm an enigma.
I was in outer space, I
grew up in a very different,
I was born in the old country.
I'm more similar to
everybody's grandfather
than I am to them.
I'm a different animal.
Don't do it like me, don't do it like you,
do it like us in our
buying into who we were
and how we could do it.
(yelling)
You got your perspective.
(audience applauding)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, really excited
about today's podcast.
Excited about the book,
but more excited about the gentleman
that's sitting in front of me.
Doug is a an iconic, I like using that,
iconic businessman and
CEO in the corporate world
and was at the helm of one of
VaynerMedia's earliest clients Campbell's
and an avid tennis fan,
which is one of the first
things I think about with him
but somebody had stayed in
touch with over the last decade
who I have a lot of respect for
and when him and his team
reached out and said,
"Hey, we've got a new book out,
"we'd love to be on the podcast."
I couldn't have been more
excited for this moment
and so here we are.
LinkedIn community I know
you're watching live.
We're taking phone numbers on Facebook
where we're live as well.
I'd really like to give
some of you access to Doug
because I think the
wisdom and the experience
and "The Blueprint" that he brings
to the forefront is a valuable one
and I'm excited to give you context.
I think a lot of times a
lot of the entrepreneurs
and executives from this
show get enormous value
of some of the great's that have done it
and I feel like Doug sits in that category
and so I'm really excited
to see you my friend.
- It's good to see you too.
- Doug, why don't you give some context
'cause I do have an audience that I think
we'll be hearing about
you for the first time
and I'm excited about that.
So why don't you give a little
two to three minute rant,
call it a comic book number
one origin story stuff.
You can go all the way back
to who you were as a kid
or go into your professional stuff
but take the floor for three
to four minutes for context
and we'll take it from there.
- Sure, I grew up in a
very modest household
outside of Chicago and--
- Were you a Bears fan?
- Oh, big time.
- Well Allen Robinson the star
wide receiver of the Bears,
literally just walked out
of here two seconds ago.
- And I missed him.
- We gotta find him.
Sheryl, go find him.
We gotta get him for Doug.
- If he's here, that'd be awesome.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's done.
We're gonna figure it out.
I don't think he left
- We're on it man.
- We're moving, improv-ing early.
Quick interrupts, just like I like it.
- Now if you could get
Rizzo or Chris Bryant here
that would be perfect.
- Well speaking of Cubs,
sports cards are back
and I'm buying Javier Baez
rookie cards like crazy.
- Oh yeah, yeah, I believe that.
- [Gary] I think Javier's
a real player so go ahead.
- All right.
- Outside of Chicago.
- So I grew up in Chicago
and migrated to the corporate
world very early on.
I tried to play professional tennis,
that lasted a nanosecond
and then discovered I
couldn't make any money,
went back finished my MBA,
went to work in the corporate world,
worked there for 40 years.
- It's unbelievable.
- My first performance review
six months into my job,
you know your boss signs it
and your boss's boss had to read it
and make a comment.
My boss' boss on my first
performance review--
- And real quick, this is
an exciting story already.
Your six months in, where are you working,
what are you doing?
- I'm working at General
Mills in Minneapolis--
- And you are a?
- I'm in brand management.
A large consumer goods company.
- What brand are you on?
- I was on Betty Crocker potato
buds and specialty potatoes.
- [Gary] I love this stuff.
- And then I moved on to
Betty Crocker brownies,
puddings and pie crusts.
I did it all there.
- You were a Betty Crocker juggernaut.
- I was writing the
message on the back panel
from Betty Crocker--
- As Betty Crocker.
- So you are Betty Crocker at some point.
- I was, yeah.
- I love this.
- My mother was in shock.
She said, "What are you doing?"
I told her I'm writing
my Betty Crocker recipe.
- I love it though,
so anyway six months in...
- Six months in I have my first review
and my boss' boss, the
only line he writes is
you should be looking for another job.
- [Gary] Really.
- You know and I've moved
to Minneapolis, Minnesota,
don't know a soul and--
- It's cold as shit.
- Yeah it is, it was March.
The first 18 days I lived there
the high temperature was below zero.
- [Gary] Unbelievable.
- So he so it's below
zero, I'm getting feedback,
you should be looking for another job,
I don't know anybody.
- How did you handle that?
- I did all right with it.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- You know you have two choices--
- [Gary] Fold or double down.
- Yeah, fold or double
down and I doubled down
and I was grinding it out.
- What did you learn from that?
What's the takeaway from that?
Was it about interactions with your boss,
was there some other random insight?
- What I learned from that probably was
that I could play through it.
But early on I was like
a deer in the headlights.
My first day at work I went
there off the tennis tour
and everybody was wearing pinstripe suits,
red ties, white shirts,
that was sort of the,
this was mid-70s.
And I show up in a khaki suit
with a bright yellow shirt,
a big wide Madras tie
and brown Earth shoes
and a tan line from where
I had my headband and--
- Mustache?
- My Fu Manchu mustache.
- [Gary] Wow.
- And here I'm showing up at
a button-down collar place and--
- Did anybody make a good funny comment
in the first 24 hours?
- No, but I--
- The looks.
- I will tell you I started
to look like everybody else
about three months in.
- [Gary] I understand.
- I spent probably my entire time there,
my focus was on fitting in
because my feedback early on
was you're not fitting in.
So I was trying to figure
out how to make this work.
It was a whole new world.
It'd be like walking in here
for the first time and--
- Yes, the energy here
is a little different.
- Wow, steroids.
- Yes.
- But at any rate and
I was trying to fit in.
- [Gary] Yes, I understand.
- And I was trying to figure out--
- Did you like the work?
I mean, obviously you stayed
in the industry for 40 years.
- Well, I liked the people.
- You liked the people.
- The work was fine--
- But you like the people part?
- It was interesting but the people--
- [Gary] I like that.
- And being part of a large community,
just like you've got here.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Being part of a larger
community of people,
give each other energy
and if you needed help,
you found somebody to help you.
- Did you like playing doubles
or in tennis you liked
more of a singles aspect?
- Both, both.
I was better at doubles but
if you're a tennis player
you're sort of a lone wolf anyway.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah, that's right.
- 'Cause it's not a team sport.
You're playing for yourself.
- So what happened immediately after that?
- Eventually I got fired from that job.
- [Gary] That's epic.
- Nine years in, I went in, I was working,
I had the world's greatest job.
I was director of marketing
for Parker Brothers Toys and Games.
- Oh.
- Nerf Sport, I had two little kids.
Nerf Sports, Nerf football--
- The green and white Nerf football
is like the most Americana for me
because that's how I became a Jets fan.
Like the Nerf spongy Nerf
green and white football
is like one of the most near
and dear things to my heart.
- A lot of us grew up with 'em.
- [Gary] Yep.
- You got one right there.
- A little leather there
but like that's what it looked like.
- Well now you've gone upscale.
- Fair enough.
- But when you started.
- Go buy me a Nerf football,
I don't want to be known
as upscale, keep going.
(laughing)
- Anyway, so I went in to work
on a beautiful spring morning.
- This is now nine years later.
- Nine years later up in Boston
and the receptionist said,
"The senior vice president of marketing
"would like to see you."
I go up to his office and he said,
"Your job's been eliminated,
"you'd need to be out of here by noon."
- Simple as that.
- And nine years of my
career was over in a snap.
- So real quick, you were General Mills
for how long before went to Parker?
- That was nine years.
General Mills owned Parker Brothers.
- I didn't know that at the time, got it.
And later sold it to Hasbro?
- Eventually yeah.
- Eventually.
- Eventually they spun it off
and then Hasbro bought it.
Yeah.
But you know it was not easy.
- How old were you, 30?
- I was 32.
- And what like crushed?
That's a tough one.
- That was the most
devastating day of my career.
- No question.
Did you have a mortgage?
- I had two kids, I had
a very large mortgage.
- [Gary] It's real stuff.
- How am I gonna make this work?
I had to go home and tell my wife.
It was not pretty.
- Not to completely go into that wound
but like you're a big
boy now and had a lot of,
wait till everybody hears.
He ended up being the CEO of Campbell's,
so like he won but like tell me about,
tell me about that day.
Who'd you call first?
I'm actually very curious
about that, was it a parent?
- I didn't call anybody,
you didn't know what to do.
- You were in a coma!
- I was told I needed
to be out of there by noon.
- [Gary] You cleaned your desk.
- Yeah, clear your desk, put it in a box.
- [Gary] Did you talk to
anybody that you worked with?
- No.
- [Gary] 'Cause you were in a daze.
- Yeah, I was absolutely in a daze.
- [Gary] Did you go to a bar right after?
- I went straight home.
- [Gary] Okay fair enough.
- Told to my wife and my two kids--
- [Gary] How old were the kids?
- The dogs, the cats.
- [Gary] How did the cats take it?
(laughing)
- I don't know, I never
talked to them about it.
- [Gary] Nonetheless.
- It was hard.
- [Gary] What happened next?
- They were so anxious to
get me out of the building
they forgot to tell me what my--
- Package was.
- Benefits,
what my package was.
So one of the HR people called me
and said I'd like to fill you in.
And I swore at him
and hung up the phone.
You know, I was so pissed.
It sort of all came out--
- Your John McEnroe came out.
- Yeah, yeah there you go.
- [Gary] And?
- And after about two more hours
with my kids running around
and the dogs and the cats.
I thought I need to get a job.
I better call that guy back.
(laughing)
- Enough of this home life.
Two hours in.
- I tell you I called
him back that same day
and they sent me to an
outplacement counselor
who saved my life, saved my life.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- That same day, I had had the
worst experience of my career
and I mean that over my 45 year career
and that afternoon and I call
my outplacement counselor guy
a guy by name of Neil McKenna,
this is before cell phones
and before caller ID.
He answers the phone, whoever
calls him and he says,
"Hello, this is Neil
Mckenna, how can I help?"
And he was there for me completely.
I called him he said, "Come right on over,
"we're gonna work through
this, we got to focus forward.
"I know this is tough stuff."
And he saved my life.
- [Gary] Wow.
- In that moment.
And you know the funny thing was,
the first thing he had me do
and we talked about this right away.
He said, "I want you to hand write
"your entire life story for
me and your family's story."
And I'm thinking what
are you talking about?
I gotta get a job.
- He wanted context.
- And you want me to hand write,
he said "Yeah, I want your hand write it.
"I want you to feel this,
hand write your life story.
"Everything.
"Everything you can think
of, leave nothing out."
So I spent two weeks writing my life--
(laughing)
Two weeks writing my life story.
- [Gary] No wonder you have a book.
- When you're unemployed
you have a lot of time.
- You have time.
- You have a lot of time,
so I wrote for two weeks
and it was unbelievable.
- And in third grade Suzy
Thompson and I like--
- No.
But I was writing about my
family coming to this country,
finding their way and all of a sudden
my losing a job paled in significance.
- Seemed small, love that.
- And I know your family same thing.
- [Gary] Perspective, it's powerful.
- And all the sudden I had
a different perspective
and I'm looking at this and I'm saying,
"God, I gotta get over this."
- [Gary] Good for you.
- This is not the worst
thing that's happened
to my family in my history.
- [Gary] Right yeah.
- And so it really helped
me get some perspective
- [Gary] And then what happened?
- This is what was interesting.
He read the story and he got to know me
and within another two
weeks when we met he said,
"I don't get it, this
just doesn't add up."
And I said, "Why?"
He said, "The person who wrote this story
"is a fierce competitor and is determined
"to make a difference.
"And you're showing up--"
- [Gary] Tail between the legs.
- Yeah "And you're not showing up,
"the person I'm reading about
"and the person I'm meeting
are two different people."
I'm an introvert, even
more then than I am now
and I wasn't talking unless spoken to.
I was very polite, I was trying to fit in,
make it work, keep my job and do all this.
- [Gary] Defense.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I was reacting to things and he said,
"You've got so much to offer,
"but you're keeping it
all bottled up inside."
And that's where the spirit of
this book started to be born
because you know my observation
and we do a little story,
David Brooks from the New
York Times writes about,
are you living for your
resume or your eulogy?
Are you trying to get
all the tangible things,
the new car,
the corner office, are you living for that
or are you living for
what they're gonna say
about you when you're gone?
And he said, "You get seduced
living for your resume."
And I started realizing that
you got to put your resume
and your eulogy together
and it should be meant together
with a sense of purpose
that grows out of your life story
not out of all the testing
and all this other stuff,
grows out of your life story
because as we see in the book,
your life story is your leadership story.
It's where it comes from.
- I met with a young woman
that doesn't work here
and she wants to go do something
and she's not leaving
because she's worried
that her resume's gonna
show she only worked
at this place for six months.
I was like it's 2020, nobody
even fucking reads resumes.
What are you talking about?
- That's a good point.
When I lost my job it's
like you were ashamed
that you lost a job and
you didn't tell anybody.
- People still are that way.
Stigma's are real.
So what happened with your career?
Where did you get picked up?
- I ended up going to Kraft,
had a good run at Kraft,
where I met Peter and Carl.
- Did you go to Chicago?
- I went back to Chicago,
tail between my legs to a degree
because that's where I grew up.
- Yeah, but Kraft was a job.
- I had a great job there.
- What was the entry point, what brand?
- I was a category manager
for Kraft salad dressings,
but I went on to be director
of corporate strategy at Kraft
and then I got recruited right after
"Barbarians at the Gate"
by KKR, I got recruited--
- Tell everybody a little bit about,
this is an iconic book
in the corporate world.
I want some of the
youngsters and entrepreneurs
outside the corporate world to hear this.
Tell everybody just a few seconds
on that iconic book and story.
- Well this was the story of
the second half of the 20th century,
it was the world's
largest LBO at the time,
it was KKR buying RJR Nabisco.
RJR was a money machine, tobacco machine.
They acquired Nabisco and
some other food companies
and built this massive business
but the handwriting was on the
wall for the tobacco industry
and so business started to soften.
KKR came in and made it
the world's largest LBO.
They planned to flip it in
five years, it took us 10.
And there was so much money
coursing through the
veins of this company that
it was like the Wild West of
corporate spending and this is--
- Wasting.
- Yeah, there were stories of
the chairman who since passed
sending the corporate
jet to pick up his dog
on the East Coast to come out
to Mission Hills, California
for a golf tournament on the West coast.
- The dog?
- The dog.
And we had a team.
He had assembled a team of
the greatest athletes of all time.
- [Gary] Oh, I know this story.
- The Johnny Unitas, all of them,
they really had no income
in their retirement,
they hadn't made the money, right?
They had about 30 people on payroll
who lived off RJR Nabisco
and showed up at events
and everything else.
It was a larger payroll I
believe than the Yankees
at the time but it was the
who's who of Hall of Fame land--
- 'Cause he loved sports.
And just wanted hang out with those guys?
- Yeah, hang out.
And you know, it worked.
It was just amazing excess.
KKR bought it, we had a
sort of wind all that down
because corporate governance
was getting in the way.
I mean you couldn't do
some of that stuff and so--
- [Gary] Cleaned it up.
- we ended up taking a lot of cost out.
I had a good run there.
The last five years I was
president of Nabisco Foods
running that and then we sold that
actually back to Kraft, who I had left
and then I was recruited to go help
fix Campbell's Soup Company,
which I was there for a decade as CEO
and that was wild.
I went in there and
headquartered in Canada.
- How did that feel?
Remind me, I apologize,
was it directly to CEO?
- Yeah.
- So how did that feel?
How did it feel on the dawn of knowing
you're getting offered the CEO job
of one of the most iconic American,
I mean this is now your
full career at this point
from the early days and Parker
Brothers and General Mills.
- From you should be
looking for another job.
You should be clean out
your desk, now I'm CEO.
- Are you more like me, did
you try to find those two guys
that wrote that review the
night before you took--
- I'm not you.
- Yeah, I would have found those fuckers.
(laughing)
And be like, Hey!
Ronald, I got something for you.
- They know, they know.
- Of course they know, I know they know.
Was that a--
- It was awesome.
- It was a head hunter?
Was it a head hunter?
- Yeah, but we had been acquired
and the market knew I was
not gonna go back to Kraft.
So there were several
opportunities percolating.
I ended up taking the Campbell's one.
- Were they all CEO jobs or?
- Yeah.
- Got it.
- That's the only one I would've done.
- Go to at that point in your career.
I get it.
Was it exciting?
- I always said you know,
I'm slow so I'm not as fast as you
but I had always said I want
to be a CEO by the time I'm 49
and I was 49 when it happened.
- This you'll find funny, Doug.
I speak fast, my energy's fast,
but I'm actually wildly slow
like even this company I'm running now.
When we met way back when for some org,
this has been built really to buy brands.
I'm far more KKR, far more private equity,
than I am agency like
I'm actually going slow.
The energy's high.
I would argue 49's a pretty
young age at that time of year
of that era to be the CEO of
something like Campbell's.
It was fast.
- It was.
- It's pretty cool.
- Yeah, well it was.
- What was the biggest challenge
with that kind of family,
there's a lot of challenges going,
I happen to have enough knowledge to know
like the Campbell's family died,
like there's some dynamics there.
- The family owned half the company
and they were five families
because it was third generation.
You know, multiple generations.
- [Gary] That's right, tricky.
- And we were headquartered in the poorest
most dangerous city in the United States
Camden, New Jersey.
- [Gary] Challenge.
- 75,000 people, 70 murders a year.
And we were running, it
was a canned soup company.
I mean our product had been
invented in the prior century
and was unchanged and I was saying,
I was talking to our folks and I said,
"Don't we need to evolve?"
And they said, "You don't understand,
"we can run canned soup
faster on our lines
"than anybody else."
And I said, "But don't we need more?"
And they said, "But we run
our canned soups really fast."
And so we evolved but the company--
- What's the biggest
highlight for you personally
in that decade?
If I'm saying to you in that
10-year window, hot take--
- You know we talked earlier
about your resume or eulogy,
that came together for me.
I showed up more authentically--
- During that era.
- In that era,
actually the last five years at Nabisco
I started to mature, I found my sea legs,
I developed the courage of my convictions
that I probably hadn't had before.
- [Gary] Love that.
- But being challenged
by KKR all the time.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And the people around there.
- [Gary] Got some teeth.
- Five years in I sort
of hit stride and said,
"You know I can do this."
- Good for you.
- So at Nabisco and then
a Campbell I hit my stride
and it became one.
What I do today I live for my resume
but I very much it's in harmony
with the things I hope
people say about me someday.
- Talk to me about the book
and talk to me about the awesome Amy
who has a big title in the book here
and I'm looking and--
- The awesome Amy is truly awesome.
I'll tell you, I'm a
68 year old white guy.
- [Gary] I've heard.
- And I'm writing this
book and I would write it
like a 68 year old white guy.
- [Gary] Respect.
- The book is designed and
we'll talk about in a minute
to be approachable for
anyone and I needed help
and Amy's a 30-something gifted writer.
She writes all the social,
she's editor in chief
for ConantLeadership.
She writes all of our
social media content.
- And what is ConantLeadership
for everybody?
- Excuse me?
- What's ConantLeadership?
- It's what we run to promote leadership
that works in the 21st century
because most of the models--
- Is it a consulting business?
For everybody who's watching,
is it a consulting business?
- We don't any consulting,
we don't make money,
I don't take a salary.
We charge for a few
things to cover our costs.
If we more than cover our
costs, we give it away and--
- It's a legacy play.
- And we've been doing this
now for like seven years.
- Good for you.
- And and we're loving it.
We're in it for all the right reasons.
- Is the book out?
- The book just came out yesterday.
- Congratulations.
Who do you feel like this is gonna hit
most right in the kind of chest?
- This can hit anybody from
my kids who are 33, 35, and 38
on up and that could actually
work with college students.
The beauty of this book is
there is no one right way to lead.
And if I talk about
your leadership story is your life story,
your life story is your
leadership story, excuse me,
your life story's unique.
- Snowflake.
- And you should lead
in a unique way.
There are some timeless
principles that you should apply,
which we talk about in the book
but this book is designed for you
to create your own blueprint.
You, anybody in this room
and it will all be different.
I have probably, because I'm older,
I have thousands of books.
Probably over a thousand
books in the office
and there are a thousand
books that tell you
how you oughta lead
and none of them resonate
with me completely.
They're good, a good idea
here, good idea there.
So what we decided to do was write a book
that help people figure out how to lead
in a way that worked for them.
- How much is relationship with adversity
and losing self esteem, self-awareness,
how many of these--
- I mean, it's all part of it.
This is complicated.
If it was not complicated--
- [Gary] Everybody would do it.
- It would have been figured out already.
- And the key to this book
is and all those other books,
it's like a diet after the holidays,
you say I'm gonna lose 20 pounds
and here we go, my wife and
I are gonna start a diet.
We last about two weeks and we say,
this is never gonna work,
it doesn't fit in our life.
And the way we wrote this book was
it has to nest perfectly,
the change process, perfectly
in your cockamamie life,
the way it exists today.
Anybody in your office, all of whom,
everybody, feels swamped.
- 100%.
- Swamped, right?
- It's unbelievable.
- And they say how do I fit this in?
- I watch people who have
one hours worth of work
feel like they're swamped
and I want to kick them in the face.
(laughing)
No, it's true it's the human spirit.
People fill their bucket with--
- [Dough] With stuff.
- Let me make fun of myself.
I thought I was the
hardest-working guy going at 27,
I laugh at that kid.
- [Doug] Well you were
pretty hard working.
- I was.
- I knew you then. (laughing)
- But really you know
you hit different gears,
hit in strides, right?
- That's true.
- It is around happiness
or what you're supposed to be doing.
- Amy, jump in here for a second,
I just wanna ask, go
ahead, don't be scared.
I just wanna you a quick question.
From your perspective
'cause I think it really
matters and gonna help,
you know from your perspective
as this book was written
what stood out to you?
What was an a-ha for you
maybe going through the process,
which I think sometimes happens
or what was your ambition
or as you were listening
and debating and conjuring up with Doug,
when you now look at this
as a finished product
where do you go with like oh,
I'm really glad this
happened through the process
or I'm excited to see this
group of people absorb this
and I'm excited, like some
random thoughts on that front.
- Yeah, so I think one of
the epiphanies was anchoring
this story in that moment
of Doug getting fired
because it brings somebody
with such gravitas
down to earth, makes them relatable
and it really is the story of
the worst day in somebody's life--
- Becoming the best.
- How to get from that day
and how do you get there
and it's a practical guide,
so when you look at a story that big
it can feel too big to be approachable.
So that's how, we also
had kind of the epiphany
to make it really practical.
People that I talk to
my age also feel swamped
whether they only have an
hour of work or 70 hours.
And they're saying I don't feel,
I need to wait for the perfect conditions
to get started on a change process.
When am I gonna feel ready?
You're never gonna feel ready.
So this is for you whenever.
- How much do you feel
that is people's inability
to have a relationship with
other people's judgment?
- I'm sorry, say that one more time.
I need to think about that.
- Sure, well I think like to your point
and I couldn't agree with you more,
like people come up with
enormous amounts of counterpoints
to why this is a time to do something
that would make them
happier, more successful.
And so it's something
I've been thinking about my whole life.
I think one of the great
gifts that I was given is
immigrant, grew up with very little,
and then on top of it which
is rare for immigrants,
bad student, right?
That's an added element,
which very early on gave me
a relationship with losing
and being an outsider that
made me very comfortable
with not worrying about people's judgment
and I observe and I'm like right,
they're scared to quit their good job
because they're unhappy
because they're worried
about their mom's judgment,
their husband's judgment,
their best friend's judgment.
In what you just said how
much have you observed
or what's your hypothesis
on how much of this
is actually grounded in people's inability
to deal with other people's judgment?
- Yeah, that's a really good point
and you're actually lucky
that you failed early
because you got comfortable with it.
- Agreed.
- There's a lot of people
especially who ascend to
the levels of leadership,
the leaders Doug's talking to,
where they're used to being really type A
and high achieving and
they're not comfortable
with something that's imperfect.
So the message in this
book is forget perfection,
throw it out the window.
- I hate perfection.
- It's not gonna be perfect.
You just have to get going.
- Perfection is a disguise
for not wanting to do.
- Absolutely, it becomes an
excuse to just not even start.
100%, yeah.
- [Gary] I love that.
- And what Amy's
engineered in here is this
you can start right
now with what you have,
with what you've got right away
and within a week you can
start to behave in a way
that works for you.
- Is there any questions?
Let's get one question before we wrap up
and then I'll give you the floor
to give some thought to the
last things we want to say
before we head out of here.
Yeah, it just makes sense.
You know it's really funny.
Podcast form, book form,
you know ultimately I think
why I wasn't a good student
is my relationship with reading.
I was never diagnosed
but it's clear to me.
I love that people learn
in different formats.
- [Amy] Yes.
- I love that.
(phone ringing)
- Who's this?
- Adam.
(phone ringing)
Adam, don't blow your only chance.
Here comes one more, Adam.
I hope we get a voice
message so I can leave one.
- [Adam] Hello, this is Adam.
- Adam, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
(Adam laughing)
- [Adam] How's it going?
- It's going quite well,
say hello to Doug and Amy.
- Hey Adam, what's going on?
- [Adam] Hey Doug, hey Amy.
It's going pretty well, how are you?
- [Gary] Good, what's
your question brother?
- [Adam] You know I just I know,
I have done some research in the past.
I'm actually writing a blog right now.
It's kind of funny that I'm even on this
but I'm ready to blog right now
and it's about just talking
about employees and clients
and just showing appreciation
and specifically how to write
the perfect thank you note
and I know a little bit of Doug's history
and how he has written I believe
over 30,000 thank you notes
and I just kind of
wanted to pick his brain
as far as like the impact
of just simply showing
appreciation and being genuine
and like what that means
and how do you do that
and any suggestions with that and yeah.
- Hey, well go to ConantLeadership.com,
and we'll help you even more but--
- Oh! (imitating cymbals)
- But lemme tell you.
- Doug, hold on.
First, you have to thank this guy
for knowing that history about you.
- Well everybody, I'm
surprised you don't Gary.
- You know what I did know
about the thank-you notes.
Is the number in the range?
- Nah, he's right.
- I did know big time
on the thank-you notes,
I didn't know, I mean that is scale.
- Well you know and Gary, thank you,
when Adam, thank you.
When I job, my outplacement
counselor said,
"You're gonna be a horrible interviewer.
"You're too shy, you're too introverted.
"You got to figure out a way
to have a signature practice
"to get a job", and he
said, "Figure it out."
So I started, I'd come
here, I'd meet 10 people.
I'd get all their names
while I was interviewing.
I would go to the coffee shop next door.
I would hand write a note to each of them.
I would then walk it
back to the front desk,
give it to the receptionist
and say could you deliver these today?
I did that everywhere I went.
- [Gary] Wow.
- And I started the
practice of reaching out
in a personal way, it
doesn't have to be much.
Receptionist had never received
a personal thank you note
in their life from somebody
calling on the building.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- And so I started doing that
and then I went to work at Campbell
and even in Campbell,
which was hemorrhaging,
eight out of 10 things
being done we're right.
We had to make some real tough decisions,
let go 300 of the top 350 leaders.
Never been done in Fortune 500 history.
At the same time we had all
these people doing good work
so I started writing 10 to 20 short notes
a day to employees,
I was commuting two and
a half hours each way
from New Jersey down to Camden,
from Morris County down to Camden.
I started reading all the
stuff that was going on
in the company and I would
write notes to these folks,
10 to 20 a day, six days
a week for a decade.
When I was retiring the
person from Forbes said,
"How many of these, I'm
hearing about all these notes
"from everybody, how many
notes have you written?"
I said, "I don't know."
So we did the math, during
the interview we did the math
and figured out just to Campbell employees
I had written 30,000 notes.
We only had 20,000 employees.
Wherever you went in the world,
we were in 38 countries,
we were marketed in 125 countries.
Wherever you went in
the world in a cubicle
if I was to walk, you would see a note
handwritten note from me--
- That's amazing.
- In just about every
person's cubicle somewhere.
- You know what's amazing about that?
Adam, any parting shots
'cause I'm gonna wrap up here
but thank you for that.
- [Adam] That's awesome.
- Adam, make it personal
and keep it short.
- [Adam] Awesome, thank you so much.
- You got it brother.
It's funny, a lot of
people don't know this
but in my transition
from the wine business
to the tech world,
I reply to every single tweet
from 2007 to 2011, period.
Anybody who replied to me and I think--
- I can only, yeah.
- But it's the same game you played.
In makes, in context, right?
- Before Twitter, yeah.
- You know like sending a
note to Amy and being like,
I liked your black and white jacket
that you wore in the office today.
Like when you actually
are paying attention,
when you actually know a little something,
it's subtle little things that really,
it's listening.
- I gotta tell you though,
the notes I wrote we're not
gratuitous, I like your jacket.
They were, you delivered the
business on plan under budget
or nice job with the diversity network.
Every note I sent was
reaffirming our company strategy
and I was talking performance,
but you know the theme was
I'm gonna be tough minded on standards.
We let a lot of people go
but I'm gonna be tender
hearted with people.
And the people that were
getting the work done,
they heard from me too.
- [Gary] I love that.
- So this is not about--
- Mine would've been like Amy, good job.
We got the pages in and
I also like your jacket.
- Well--
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- I wanted no mistakes.
- I respect that,
no, I respect that.
- You worry that people think oh,
we're just gonna hold
hands and sing Kumbaya.
That's not it.
- By the way,
it's back to "The Blueprint."
It's back to 11,000 books.
It's I would done that and
you would have done this
and that's the biggest punchline.
The biggest fear I have right
now is in my popularity growth
that people gonna try to be like me.
I'm an enigma.
I was in outer space.
I grew up in a very different,
I was born in the old country.
I'm more similar to
everybody's grandfather
than I am to them.
I'm a different animal.
Don't do it like me, don't do it like you,
do it like us in our
buying into who we were
and how we could do it.
- Yeah, it's your story, you write it.
- 100%.
- It's not our story.
And all these leadership
books are here's my story
and here's how you should do it.
- It's wrong.
- Forget about that.
- I'm with you, it's wrong.
- It's the wrong paradigm.
- Now if you're the kind of learner
that learns from other people's examples,
that's why you went on to read those books
because you were able
to get a little here,
a little there and at 15, 20 bucks a pop
and if you're a quick
reader, you can get value.
It's a frame work.
- There are people you can learn from.
I met Stephen Covey when
he was Stephen Covey.
He was advising presidents and I and he,
you know when the student is
ready, the teacher appears.
And he had a profound influence on me,
so did Neil McKenna who was
my outplacement counselor.
Right time, right place.
- [Gary] Right human.
- I mean there are people to learn from
but you have to listen
to your inner voice.
- [Gary] Love.
- And our observation is most people
don't know their inner voice.
They haven't reflected on it--
- Or they suppress it or they fear it
'cause it doesn't fit in
or 'cause they fear it
because they hear it
but they don't see it
fitting into the narrative
that has been forced on them.
- Right, well said.
We could have used when we wrote the book.
(laughing)
Where were you when I needed you?
- I'm here right now when it matters.
Watch this, everybody who's watching,
go to Amazon or your local book store,
BarnesandNobles.com and
pick up "The Blueprint."
Doug, Amy, thank you so much.